welcome to the coast of Argentina we're
about to witness the most primal drama
in the natural world
crafty predator versus vulnerable prey
only this drama has a big surprise
ending right now these adorable sea lion
pups are protected by a reef that looms
up during low tide when the tide rises
act one of our drama begins the bent fin
belongs to big mouth a 20 year old
killer whale that's been hunting this
beach for 17 years the jagged fin
belongs to his 30 year old brother
Bernard as the sea lion pups splash
happily in the water they're revealing
their location to the finely tuned
sonar receptors of the whales
like a dim-witted teenager in a bad
horror flick this oblivious sea lion pup
frolics in clear view of a hungry
predator and becomes his next meal
big Mel takes his shot
close but no lunch this time Barnard
takes dead a and grabs the second of the
three sea lion pups his body demands
each day that keep up his energy
the feeding frenzy is on big Mel grabs
his next pup
and Barnard soon follows with a pop of
his own
but now the brothers employ their prey
as something more than food bernard and
big mouths play no net volleyball with
they're still living victims are they
just cavorting with their products
showing off scientists believe the
whales are actually training for the
more rigorous chases they'll have to
make later in the year in the open sea
and now for that surprise ending we
promised their last catch is brought
back to shore
and set free is this an act of mercy or
play behavior we may never know